i'm audrey princess audrey
sleeping beauty's daughter we don't mean
to bother you sleeping beauty but we're
a little concerned and confused
your daughter audrey nearly destroyed
her enemies in auradon in descendants 3
but you were nowhere to be found your
mom leo was there and she even patched
things up with mal
so we just want to know why you weren't
by your daughter's bedside when haiti
saved her life
audrey could have used the support
we probably weren't the only ones who
wanted to see princess aurora into
sentence 3.
luckily audrey's mom popped up in a
popular tv series
so we finally know what she looks like
and whether or not she looks like audrey
keep watching to see what the missing
parents from descendants 3
really look like no
i don't hate my mother dizzy and
drizella
dizzy's grandmother lady tremaine might
be a total villain but her daughter's
anastasia and drizella
aren't exactly the conniving type they
just do what they're told
we never catch a glimpse of dizzy's mom
in descendants 2 and 3 but we do get to
see her in once upon a time
funny enough anna cathcart actually
played the teenage version of drizella
on the show
uma and ursula uma is one of our
favorite vk's and she's the daughter of
ursula
while we don't get to see the sea witch
in descendants 2 we do catch a glimpse
of her long tentacles
shut your clams mom these dishes ain't
gonna wash themselves
we know that actress whoopi goldberg
voiced ursula in the disney channel
movie
however we get to see a better look at
ursula in once upon a time
chad cinderella and prince charming in
2015 disney released the live-action
remake of cinderella
actress lily james portrayed cinderella
while actor richard madden played prince
charming
this movie told the tale of how
cinderella and charming fell in love
and thanks to the descendants franchise
we know that they eventually had a son
named chad
lonnie and mulan lonnie is a brave and
talented fighter who never backs down
from a fight
and she gets that from her warrior
parents mulan and lee shang
the live-action remake of mulan is
hitting the big screen on march 25th
2020 and we're super excited we'll get
to see the real-life version of lonnie's
mother mulan
doug and dopey doug has got to be the
nicest ak in auradon he never had a
problem with the vks attending auradon
prep hi guys
i'm dopey's son as in dopey doc bashful
happy grumpy
sleepy and he made everyone feel
welcomed he probably gets this from his
dad
dopey who once risked everything by
letting a stranger move into his home we
never get to see doug's dad in the
descendants movies
but he does pop up and once upon a time
ally and alice
ally is a character who doesn't appear
in the actual descendants movies
however ali is a popular ak when it
comes to the animated short series
descendants wicked world
we wish ali could have made it into d3
it would have been super cool to see
ally and alice standing side by side
luckily we know exactly what alice looks
like thanks to the live action
alice in wonderland movies audrey aurora
and phillip
much like dizzy we never get to see
audrey's parents in d3 but we do get to
meet her grandmother
our family status gone queen lia is a
real piece of work but she starts to
loosen up by the end of the three quill
we never get to see princess aurora or
prince philip
which is a total bummer but once again
we get to meet the younger versions of
audrey's parents in once upon a time
evie and the evil queen evie and the
evil queen might have their differences
but they connect over beauty and fashion
we get to see what evie's mom looks like
in the first descendants film
but it's hard to see the resemblance and
once upon a time we get to meet a very
different version of the evil queen
actress lana perea portrays evie's
soon-to-be mother on the show
ruby insulin and rapunzel much like ally
ruby and insulin
don't appear throughout the descendants
franchise but they are leading
characters in the descendants wicked
world miniseries
rapunzel is one of the most adored
disney princesses of all time
so we would have loved to see her and
her kids appear in descendants 3.
we know what rapunzel looks like as a
cartoon and thanks to once upon a time
we now know what she looks like in human
form gill and gaston
gill is the furthest thing away from
being a villain he just wants to make
friends go on adventures and try some
cool new foods rocks
giant fish you're probably used to
grabbing lunch off of a bush but his dad
gaston
isn't the chummy type gill hardly ever
mentions his father and after watching
the 2017 live-action remake of beauty
and the beast
we finally know why gaston is super
pompous and self-involved
jay and jafar we know what jafar looks
like thanks to the descendants franchise
but we were curious to see what he
looked like when he was younger
jay's dad can be seen in the 2019
live-action remake of disney's aladdin
he's portrayed by actor marwan kenzari
malin maleficent in 2015 kristin
chenoweth took the stage to portray
mao's mother maleficent in the first
descendants film
it's all about you and me baby do you
enjoy
watching innocent people suffer but we
haven't seen her since mal transformed
her into a lizard
but we get to see younger versions of
maleficent and ursula
battling it out on the episode of once
upon a time barry and captain hook
the cartoon version of captain hook was
pretty evil and outdated
thankfully once upon a time brought us a
captain hook that does his son harry a
lot of justice
both father and son are gifted in the
looks department and they're both a lot
nicer than they pretend to be
who is your favorite child parent duo
tell us in the comments
mirror mirror on the wall who's the
baddest villain parent of them all
we've got some clues about the missing
parents of the villain kids in the
disney descendants movies
watch until the end to find out which of
the villain kids might actually be
siblings
see i'm just just trying to teach you
the thing that really counts
how to be me the villains on the isle of
the lost have certainly been busy since
their banishment to that crowded chunk
of land with no magic
in descendants they established that the
villain kids mal evie
jay and carlos are the children of
maleficent the evil queen
jafar and cruella de vil respectively we
know that they didn't exactly have a
flair for a loving parenting
in fact they're downright mean and
selfish to their kids mao grows up being
praised for things like backstabbing her
best friends
evie thinks she must flirt with and
manipulate men to get what she wants
jay is a thief and carlos has an
irrational phobia of dogs
not exactly the best marks of good
parenting in the first movie the villain
parents tried to manipulate the villain
kids into stealing fairy godmother's
wand so they could destroy the barrier
around the aisle
the barrier is broken we're free
thankfully for auradon mal and her
friends chose to be good
maleficent didn't take the news very
well she took advantage of a breach in
the barrier and escaped to auradon where
she terrified
everyone when she turned into a dragon
[Music]
unfortunately for maleficent she was
magically transformed into a tiny lizard
in fact all four of the transferred
villain kids stood up to their parents
and decided to stay in auradon
all the villain kids seemed to be doing
well without their parents
in fact we haven't seen much of the
villain parents since the first movie
but fans still have one major question
about the villains on the isle
why are they all single parents we've
got some theories about the whereabouts
of these missing parents
mal's dad everyone is pretty sure that
hades is mao's dad but we won't know for
sure until descendants 3 comes out
in the novel the isle of the lost mao's
father is mentioned a few times
one thing maleficent says about mao's
dad is that he's a pathetic little human
that doesn't really match up with the
theory that mao's dad is hades
hades isn't human he's the lord of the
underworld
but was he once human before whatever
happened it's clear that it didn't work
out between mao's dad and maleficent
so that means mal's only real role model
was an angry bitter
magicless sorceress with a singular
mission of revenge
it's no wonder mal turned out decent at
all so what happened to split up mal's
parents
maybe there's only room for one
narcissistic selfish cruel parent in the
family
can you imagine an argument between
hades and maleficent
if they had access to their magic they
would have made their castle explode in
a fiery display of blue and purple
flames
one thing is certain all the fans are
excited to see mao's reunion with her
long
father but if it is hades will he be on
mao's side or is he the one draining her
magic
from the latest hades trailer that
disney released it's clear that hades
has a score to settle
he's bitter that he's been exiled to
live out his days to a crowded little
island with no magic
no freedom no hope he wants to make the
king and queen of auradon pay for what
they've done
since the king and queen are the parents
of mao's boyfriend that would put him at
odds with mal
and we know from the mystery trailer
that mal is trying to get her hands on
hades ember
so this may not be the happy
father-daughter reunion we've all been
waiting for
evie's dad we know that grim hildy aka
the evil queen is the most beautiful and
cruel queen on the isle
so who could evie's dad possibly be one
fan believes it could be gaston from
beauty and the beast
when you think about it that makes a lot
of sense he's vain like the evil queen
he wanted only the best most beautiful
woman in the land
but then belle chose the beast now
technically gaston fell
off the castle at the end of beauty and
the beast but did he really meet his
demise
according to the actor who voiced the
character the answer is no
in an interview he shared that he is 100
certain that gaston just had a bad fall
he thinks gaston probably just got a
nasty bump and may have forgotten
himself for a while
perhaps he has a bit of villain amnesia
but richard white is convinced we'll see
him again
but we're not totally convinced after
all the animators did draw skulls in the
pupils of his eyes
which is a pretty big indicator that he
didn't survive the fall
that would make it impossible for him to
be evie's dad and also that would make
evie and gill
half brother and sister speaking of half
sisters there's another fan theory that
would turn evie's bestie into her
half-sister
this fan theory points to hades as
evie's potential father
if he's also mal's dad that would make
mal and evie have
sisters if hades dated both maleficent
and the evil queen
we doubt he would live to tell the tale
but maybe he was protected from their
vengeance by being locked up
another more feasible theory is that
evie's father is the huntsman
you know the guy who ran snow white out
into the woods in the animated film
however he was supposed to bring the
queen snow white's heart in a box
and he didn't do it we can't imagine the
evil queen letting him live that one
down
jay's mom jafar is among the other evil
single parents on the isle whose past is
a bit of a mystery
besides jasmine he never had a love
interest he seemed only interested in
power and control
on the aisle he's obsessed with finding
the lamp with a genie inside so he can
make his wishes come true
but who could jay's mom actually be one
fan had quite an interesting theory
about this
when you look at jay you can see that
he's clever charismatic
nimble acrobatic and a master thief hmm
that sounds like another character from
a classic disney movie
aladdin and jay are so much alike that
it's spooky
in fact jay bears a closer resemblance
to aladdin than he does to jafar
additionally jafar talks about jasmine
on several occasions in the descendants
movie
disney fans are like expert detectives
many of them came to the conclusion that
jay might actually be the son of aladdin
and jasmine but that jafarg has some
sort of spell on them
and stole jay for himself that way he
could have someone to do his bidding
while he is stuck
on the isle so maybe jasmine and aladdin
are completely oblivious to the fact
that they may have a son
and that he's been kidnapped and that he
was stuck living out his days on the
isle of the lost
until ben invited him and the rest of
the vks to auradon
so will we be seeing more than one
parent reunion in d3
we'll have to just wait and see
mom yes who would touch up my roots
fluff my fur and
scrape the buttons off my feet carlos so
carlos's mom cruella deville is
downright frightening
she's not only ruthless against people
who get in her way but she's also not
exactly a friend to the canine world
either
she views all living beings as their to
serve her needs including her own son
she made him sleep in her closet to
protect her furs she instilled a
crippling
irrational fear of dogs in him from an
early age
she makes him scrape the bunions off of
her feet gross
she seems like the worst mother in the
bunch so who would want to marry and
have a kid with this monstrous woman
many fans have speculated that she could
have hooked up with one of her henchmen
jasper or horus another fan has
suggested king candy from wreck-it ralph
as the bad guy who stole cruella's heart
but carlos may never find out the truth
about who his father really is
cruella doesn't seem like the kind of
mother who would sit her son down for a
heart-to-heart talk
since it must get lonely on the isle
there's a chance that jafar and cruella
got together at some point
that would make carlos and jay
half-brothers that would explain their
playful chemistry
they're constantly play fighting and
wrestling around they
definitely have that brotherly energy
between them but regardless of who
carlos's dad could be
it's clear that cruella couldn't hold
down a steady relationship
that's because she views others as only
there to serve her
not to mention she keeps talking to that
stuffed dog on her shoulder
and that is just weird celia
we don't know much about celia and her
dad dr facilier yet
in an interview at the disney fan fest
judah marie shared that celia is a
daddy's girl
she also mentioned that she's all about
the cash just like her father so it
seems like they're pretty close
but who is celia's mother we would
venture to say that celia came to dr
facilier as part of a deal he made with
an
unsuspecting victim of his voodoo magic
he doesn't exactly deal
fairly with people so what if he sort of
rumple still skinned his way into having
a daughter of his own
that would make it hard to pin down her
real parents they could be
anybody who got tricked by the great
voodoo doctor the only ones who know for
sure
are his friends on the other side uma
uma clearly takes after her mother
ursula
she's got the same sass the same bad
temper and the same octopus morphing
abilities
it's gotta be hard to make room for
anyone else among all those tentacles
ursula wanted to be the queen of the sea
she tried to overthrow king triton
and wound up with a ship in the gut
instead she also went after prince eric
as vanessa when she stole
ariel's voice this sea witch will stop
at nothing to snag a royal man and take
all of his power
so what if prince eric was tricked into
falling for ursula some time after the
little mermaid
that would make prince eric uma's dad
but that doesn't quite seem to fit with
uma's personality and abilities
we think it could be king triton we're
not sure how but
maybe uma is the love child of king
triton and ursula
that would make ariel and all of her
sisters related to uma
either king triton doesn't know that uma
is his daughter or he's trying to
distance himself from
the most terrifying sea witch in the
ocean another possibility for uma's
father is the evil pirate who tried to
destroy peter pan
that's right we're talking about captain
hook this would make uma and harry half
sister and brother
that would explain their chemistry an
inseparable bond
many fans have been shipping these two
pretty hard but what if they turned out
to be related
that would be totally gross after
examining all of the villain parents on
the isle one thing
seems quite apparent none of them seem
capable of sustaining
a loving relationship they're all
selfish evil greedy vengeful lying
thieving power hungry people who
shouldn't be anyone's parents
at the end of the day that's why the vks
only have one parent each they couldn't
get along with anyone else for long
enough to create a loving family
and the parents who stuck around only
did so because they wanted to use their
kids to do their evil bidding
it's no wonder mal and the gang wanted
to flee to auradon
they had to escape a terrible upbringing
with parents who didn't love them
they only thought of themselves why do
you think the villain kids only have one
parent
do you agree with our theories about who
their parents could be you've got two of
the strongest parents in the disney
verse now
so that makes you like a pretty big deal
it's just
too bad that your dad jumped ship when
you were just a baby
he could have taught you so much about
your godly powers sure your mom was no
piece of cake but at least she stuck
around right
the mistress of evil and the god of the
underworld don't come off as a
lovey-dovey couple
but believe us when we say that it was
love at first sight
hades and maleficent may be divorced but
once upon a time they saw something
special in each other
keep watching to find out the truth
about hades and maleficent's love story
but heads up it doesn't end on a high
note
no no i left your mother
she's the big reveal
if there's one thing most vks have in
common it's having a missing parent
since the first descendants film came
out in 2015
fans have been curious to find out who
mal evie and carlos's dads are
and who jay's mom is too but it wouldn't
be until the third descendant's film
that the cat got
out of the bag despite keeping it a
secret from everyone but evie
mal finally spilled the beans and
revealed that her father was none other
than hades
the god of the underworld ben was
shocked to say the least
and more than a little terrified am i
invited to the wedding
hi dad um uh
after all hades would eventually become
his father-in-law
hades did what he had to do fans were
certain that hades would turn out to be
mao's dad and they were right
in descendants 3 mal and celia walk into
haiti's lair to steal his ember but he
catches them in the act
mao calls him dad before they join in on
the wicked duet do what you gotta do
but before they can belt out their
emotions hades reveals that he was once
married to maleficent
no i left your mother she's
not the easiest person to get along with
hades then tries to bond with mal over
the fact that they both hate maleficent
but hate is a pretty strong word so mal
denies it
saying that she doesn't hate her mom
because at least she stuck around
but what we're curious about is what
maleficent did to merit haiti's hatred
after all he once loved her enough to
marry her
but then again both hades and maleficent
don't have the best track record
the big bad maleficent maleficent is
said to be the incarnation of pure evil
she takes the small things to heart like
being left out on a guest list
maleficent is the antagonist of the 1959
disney movie sleeping beauty
and she's known for sentencing king
stephen and queen leah's baby girl
aurora to die on the eve of her 16th
birthday
luckily for aurora meriwether alters the
curse condemning their kingdom to a
lifetime of sleep
if the princess should ever prick her
finger on the spindle of a spinning
wheel
maleficent has done some awful things
but cursing a baby is by far her evilest
deed
and it's something she has in common
with hades the big bad hades
just like maleficent's story haiti's
story also begins with a christening
his nephews to be exact convinced that
he should be the one to rule over mount
olympus
instead of his brother zeus hades plans
to overthrow him
problem is there's a prophecy about
zeus's son hercules
should hercules ever grow to be 18 years
old he'll be strong enough to beat hades
and the titans
so what does hades do he sends pain and
panic to turn hercules into a mortal
and end his life to prevent the prophecy
from coming true
both hades and maleficent committed
terrible crimes against helpless
children
proving that they were a match made in
the underworld
maleficent's love story maleficent
hasn't had the easiest run when it comes
to love which is probably why hades
found it hard to be married to her
long before hades and maleficent tied
the knot captain hook tried to get
maleficent on board
but she zapped him with her staff until
his hook was all that he had left
but in 2014 film maleficent we find out
that the mistress of evil
was once in love with king stefan who
she had met in the forest of the moors
unfortunately for her the king returned
her love by cutting off her wings
sparking the rivalry that led to
princess aurora's purse
so by the time hades came along he had
his work cut out for him
hades love history before we tell you
exactly how maleficent and hades fell in
love
let's find out about haiti's romantic
past long before haiti starred as the
villain in hercules story
he lived on in greek mythology as the
story goes hades who hated living in the
cold and
lonely underworld kidnapped and married
persephone
he forced her to live with him for a
full six months before striking a deal
with her
and letting her rejoin her family for
the rest of the year despite being
kidnapped persephone eventually came to
love hades but by the time hercules hit
the big screen in 1997
persephone was nowhere to be found so as
it turns out hades has had not one
but two divorces and he dated someone on
the isle of the lost
after maleficent too but more on that
later
go away mother love at first fight
both hades and maleficent have appeared
in a handful of walt disney productions
so they met
long before the isle of the lost was
created in season one of disney villains
the series
maleficent is sent to retrieve one of
chernabog's precious items from
hades maleficent obeys her master and
goes to the underworld to find the
stolen artifact
hades immediately blasts maleficent with
all his might and is super impressed
when he sees that she's still standing
80s and maleficent have a love at first
sight moment
halloween with hades in another walt
disney series called house of mouse
maleficent and hades come face to face
once again
hey there hi there oh there miss
maleficent
hey see that's a real swell bird you got
but this time hades is the only one
swooning
after getting rejected by maleficent a
handful of times
edis goes to mickey mouse for some help
so mickey teaches hades how to be a nice
guy
and even dresses him up in a mickey
outfit but when hades tries to woo
maleficent in his new outfit
she turns him down telling him how much
he hates nice guys
hades goes full on hades when he gets
shut down and even threatens to turn
mickey into a roasted mouse that's when
maleficent finally sees haiti's evil
side
and sparks fly these two definitely had
a history before winding up on the isle
of the lost
so why did their relationship take such
a sour turn
the new hades in october of 2019
maleficent mistress of evil hit the big
screen and fans were quick to point out
that conald the leader of the dark frey
is the maleficent movie's version of
hades
sure he and hades don't look alike or
act alike but they both have a common
goal
to free maleficent of the people she
serves 80s helped maleficent escape from
turnabough and disney villains this
series
so there could be a link there fans
would have loved to see hades and
maleficent featured in the same
live-action disney film
but that has yet to happen now that we
know who hades and maleficent were
before appearing in the descendants
franchise
let's take it way back to when mal was
born the villains and a baby
mao's story begins 20 years after beast
and fairy godmother revive
and trapped the villains on the isle of
the lost but at this time mal
is only 16 years old so that means that
hades and maleficent were dating
or married for a full four years before
mal was born
we know that hades walked out when mao
was just a baby so something big
had to have happened for hades to throw
in the towel hades and maleficent were
definitely in love and yet
before she could start walking and
talking mal's parents got a divorce
and hades wound up hating maleficent
with a passion
so what happened let's look at some
theories
no justice no revenge maleficent hades
and the rest of the villains
were used to being free and powerful and
being locked up on the aisle meant that
they were trapped and powerless
we all saw how enraged hades was over
beast's decision
he was literally going crazy there was
no justice or
revenge to be had instead the villains
were trapped like animals and treated as
such
chances are maleficent's need for
revenge became all she could talk about
and seeing as hades wasn't coming up
with any master plans
it's possible that she lost respect for
him and started treating him poorly
80s goes berserk there's no use denying
it hades lost his marbles after a few
years of living on the isle
before getting locked up on the isle all
hades had to do was snap
his fingers to get what he wanted but
after the isle 80s had to do
everything with his own two hands and
the same goes for maleficent
taking care of a newborn baby as an
average human being does
isn't an easy task for an all-powerful
villain chances are maleficent and hades
had more than a few spats
leading hades to walk out on his wife
and daughter
powerless there are so many reasons why
hades would hate maleficent with a
passion
but we don't exactly know what went down
between them but what we do know however
is that maleficent finds powerful
and evil men attractive and seeing as
hades went from being the god of the
underworld to a powerless stay-at-home
dad
it sort of makes sense that maleficent
would stop loving him
after getting herself a daughter she
might very well have been the one to
break things off with hades
this would totally explain why hades
hates maleficent
after all he obviously has a soft spot
for mal
who he watched grow up from afar 80.
instead of moping around and trying to
win maleficent back haiti's moved on to
someone new
and guess what in return to the isle of
the lost a descendant's novel he ended
up having another kid by an unknown
mother who he named haiti
haiti is part of the younger villains in
the anti-heroes clue
so it's safe to assume that he was born
much after mao
one of the reasons why hades and
maleficent never got back together
could have everything to do with little
haiti's existence
after all maleficent isn't one to
forgive easily
by the end of descendants 3 mal gained
both a father
and a half brother despite him not
making an appearance in the film
one big happy family the question on
everyone's lips
is will mal's parents ever get back
together well chances are if maleficent
and hades attend mao's royal wedding
they might be reminded of their own and
fall in love all over again
but first mal would have to find and
turn that poor lizard back into the
mighty maleficent again
and who knows how that'll go would you
like to see maleficent and hades in a
live-action disney movie
sound off in the comments
maleficent you're one of the most
terrifying disney villains of all time
but despite the terrors you've unleashed
we can't help but feel sorry for you we
mean you're still a lizard for crying
out loud
all you wanted was for your daughter mal
to bring down the barrier but
things got a little mixed up along the
way but we thought you should know that
she succeeded
too bad the victory is more than a
little bittersweet we hope you don't
take it badly if you don't get invited
to the royal wedding
because we all know what happens when
your invite gets lost in the mail
she shall prick her finger on the
spindle of a spinning wheel
the united states of auradon and the
isle of the lost have more connections
than you may think
watch until the end to find out who the
parents of your favorite aks and
vks are you won't believe how many
disney heroes
mal is related to no
i don't hate my mother dizzy tremaine
the sweet and talented dizzy tremaine is
one of the most popular bks for obvious
reasons
unlike her family dizzy is kind-hearted
and ready to fight for what's right
dizzy is the daughter of drizella
tremaine however her mother doesn't make
an appearance in the descendants movies
instead dizzy is shown to have been
predominantly raised by her grandmother
lady tremaine a popular theory states
that hans from disney's frozen is
dizzy's father
and hey if the shoe fits but while we're
on the topic of shoes
let's take a look at disney's extended
family dizzy's stephane is none other
than cinderella making chad charming and
dizzy first cousins through marriage
dizzy's closest relatives are her six
sisters her aunt anastasia
and her cousin anthony tremaine king
benjamin
without king ben the people of the isle
would still be in prison today
his big heart and forward views changed
the kingdom of auradon for the better
finn is the only son of power couple
beast in belle
but despite being raised under the roof
and rules finn developed
life-changing opinions of his own it's
time for forgiveness
it's time for a new beginning once ben
and mao get married ben will be the
son-in-law of the wicked maleficent and
hades
but ben's family tree is connected to a
handful of other disney characters
there's a theory that princess jane from
tarzan is the descendant of belle
both princesses bear a striking
resemblance and wear the same colored
dress
and since tarzan is said to be elsa and
anna's long-lost brother
ben may be loosely related to the queen
and princess of arendelle
uma uma is the villain turned hero who
stole our hearts in descendants 3.
she's the only daughter of ursula the
sea witch and she's super proud of her
heritage
uma's father isn't in the picture but
tons of fans are certain that dr fasolir
is her long-lost
dad this would make celia and uma half
sisters which would explain their
special bond in descendants 3.
when you think about it ursula and dr
fasolir would make an awesome couple
they both use dark magics persuasion and
song to con their victims into signing
binding contracts that always come with
a hefty price
keep watching to find out how uma and
mao's family trees
could be connected celia fasolire
cilia fasciliar was first introduced in
descendants 3.
she's the daughter of dr fasolir and is
known for being a total daddy's girl
you make sure you get your cut although
she isn't mentioned in the movies
celia has an older sister named freddie
fasselier who appears in the animated
short series
descendants wicked world if our
assumptions are right celia and
freddie are uma's half-sisters oddly
enough china and mclean who plays
uma used to voice freddie's character in
wicked world
however once chyna was casazuma her role
as freddie was passed down to her
real-life sister
lauren mclean now why would the disney
channel do this
if there weren't any family trees
between uma and the facilities
carlos deville the adorable carlos
deville was born and raised on the isle
of the lost but his mother cruella
deville raised him to be
more of a servant than anything to
control him cruella convinced carlos
that dogs were ferocious beasts who
could not be trusted
when in reality it was cruella who is
the most rabid one of all
carlos may be an only child but he has a
first cousin named diego
and an uncle named cecile b deville
diego
appears in novels like the isle of the
lost and returned to the isle of the
lost but didn't make it into the disney
channel movies once carlos marries jane
he'll be the son-in-law of the wonderful
fairy godmother
jane jane is an auradon kid who knows
that love will conquer all
she fell for carlos deville in
descendants 2 and hasn't looked back
since
would you be my date
for cotillion jane is the only daughter
of the enchanting fairy godmother
she was raised to always do the right
thing which is what attracted carlos to
jane in the first place
jane is super close to chad charming for
more reasons than one
first of all furry godmother and
cinderella see each other as
family which is why we aren't surprised
that chad and jane
have a cousin vibe going on between them
once jane and carlos tie the knot she'll
be the very terrified daughter-in-law of
cruella
de vil harry hook there's no one quite
like hairy hook
the only son of captain hook from
disney's peter pan harry aspires to be
like his father
going as far as holding the fake hook to
give off the same vibe
harry may appear to be an only child in
the descendants movies but the
descendants novels and
animated tv series beg to differ harry
has an
older sister named harriet hook and a
younger sister named
cj hook cj is pictured to have blonde
hair and descendants wicked world
which makes us wonder who harry's real
mother could be the only blonde haired
disney villain out there
is helga sinclair from atlantis the lost
empire and if you need more proof than
that helga's last name ties harry to his
scottish heritage
after all the name sinclair derives from
a reputable scottish clan
evie evie is the only daughter of the
evil queen from disney snow white
she was raised to be vain calculating
and sophisticated but managed to lead
with her heart instead
we could try to be friends put our
history behind us and celebrate our
differences
at the moment no one knows who evie's
real father is but many fans believe
that hades is both
mal and evie's father this would make
and evie half sisters however there
isn't enough proof to support this
theory which is why evie's father
remains a mystery
but since queen grimhild was married to
snow white's father
this would make evie and snow white step
sisters
but unlike the evil queen evie isn't
jealous of her step-sister's good looks
because evie
is the fairest of them all jay
jay is the only member of the core 4 to
know who his father is instead of his
mother
i already tried jay is the only son of
jafar from disney's aladdin but his
family tree doesn't end
there a disney inspired video game
called nesira's revenge revealed that
jafar has a fraternal twin sister named
nasira
who also wound up on the isle of the
lost and jay's aunt nasira has a
daughter named
jade who is close to jay's age although
she doesn't appear in the descendants
movies
she was mentioned in the isle of the
lost book so despite not knowing who his
mother is
jay still has close female relatives
lonnie lonnie is an auradon kid who
loves to test boundaries she's the
daughter of fa mulan
and lee shang and she means business
just like her mother
lonnie desires to break the mold and
show the world that girls can do
anything boys can do
lonnie is lucky enough to have two
supportive parents and a family home in
northern way
her great great-grandmother is grandma
fa and her grandparents are faw zoo
and spa lee out of all the aks and bks
lonnie's family appears to be the most
normal
gill if you need a friend gil is always
there to lend a helping hand
gill is a simple vk who loves adventure
and learning new things
you know what would be fun to go rafting
in a jungle river
find a lot of civilization oh maybe a
penguin he's the son of gaston from
disney's beauty and the beast but he's
nothing
like his father gaston had three
children gaston jr gaston iii
and gill the guest on sons have never
mentioned who their mother
is but in this case we think it's much
better to ask who their mothers are
the bim vets from beauty and the beasts
were head over heels for gaston
and since there's three of them it's
possible that gaston had a son with each
of them
claudette lauret and paulette weren't
the sharpest tools in the shed
which could be why gill isn't always
quick to get the joke
princess audrey unlike many other disney
princesses
audrey is royal on both sides of the
family her mother princess aurora is the
daughter of king stefan and queen leia
where it's her father prince philip is
the son of king hubert and his unnamed
wife
audrey's parents didn't play huge roles
in the descendants movies but her
grandmother
queen leia sure did despite being born
into a loving household
audrey turned out to be a brat but by
the end of descendants 3 she really came
full circle
audrey also has a cousin named ariana
rose who was introduced in the escape
from the isle of the lost
a descendant's novel despite being
cousins audrey and ariana rose
don't really get along chad charming
chad charming is the son of cinderella
and prince charming
but his status just isn't good enough
for audrey despite being raised by the
caring and hardworking cinderella
chad is nothing like his mom chad wants
nothing more than to make audrey happy
first off great new one so he agrees
that the vks belong on the isle
and nowhere else but unlike audrey chad
has a huge extended family on the isle
of the lost
his mother's stepsisters drizella and
anastasia have families of their own
this makes chad's step cousins with
dizzy her six sisters and
anthony tremaine we wonder if chad will
warm up to his extended family
now that the barrier has been taken down
doug doug is one of the sweetest ardent
kids of all time which makes him
compatible with the fashion forward evie
dove is the son of dopey from disney
snow white
and he was raised to help those in need
the name of doug's mother is never
mentioned throughout the films but we do
see dopey standing next to a beautiful
woman at ben's coronation
and she's believed to be doug's mother
despite coming off as an only child
doug has a handful of brothers mal the
future queen of auradon has got one
complicated family tree she's the
daughter of maleficent and hades
who are some of the most powerful disney
villains of all time
hades is the brother of zeus and
poseidon which makes mal first cousins
with
hercules and since king triton is the
son of poseidon mal's also cousins with
princess ariel
mal has a half-brother called haiti who
is strictly introduced and returned to
the isle of the lost a descendant's
novel
if you're wondering how uma and mao
might be related it's through king
triton
and ursula disney executives originally
wanted to make ursula
ariel's aunt but they chose to leave it
out of the script still are slit hints
to having lived in the castle with king
triton causing fans to peg them as
siblings
so mao could be connected to uma through
her father's godly roots
who is your favorite descendants
character and why
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back descendants fans want to
learn why evie starts out being obsessed
with looks and finding a prince
dive into her fascinating backstory with
us where we speculate on who her father
could be
keep watching to discover which friend
she used to crush on and which friend
used to be her enemy does this vest make
me look fat
all about evie let's start out with a
quick character appraisal of evie
and the journey she goes on in the first
two descendants movies we first meet
evie on the isle
being wicked with the rest of the vks
it's not surprising she's so obsessed
with mirrors and looks given that she's
the daughter of the evil queen from snow
white and the seven dwarfs but more on
mommy dearest later
evie is all about finding a prince when
she gets to auradon and she lines up
chad charming as the perfect person to
get her a castle but she discovers that
there's more to a partner than being
next in line to the throne
especially when chad uses her to do his
homework then tries to get her expelled
evie's journey of self-discovery dopey's
son doug
helped cv realize that she doesn't have
to play dumb to get a guy
she's actually really smart with an
aptitude for chemistry
after she gets a b-plus in her chemistry
exam she has the revelation that she's
more than just a pretty face
she also has an aptitude for business
too when she sets up her eevees for
hearts fashion line
she understands the benefits of work and
as doug points out in the next three
years she'll be able to buy her own
castle that way she won't need a prince
and edie agrees because she has him
talk about a turnaround unlike her bff
mal
evie is obviously excited about being at
auradon prep
we love the look on her face when she
sees her dorm room and by descendants 2
she's encouraging mao to embrace the
opportunity they've been given
evie knows that auradon girls can be
whatever they want to be and she knows
she's lucky enough to have been given a
chance
which is why she wants to extend that
chance to other kids from the isle
at the end of the second film she asks
ben to bring dizzy over
and a whole list of other kids she
doesn't forget where she's come from
though
[Music]
we're always gonna be the kids from the
aisle that's their roots
and what they had to do to survive back
then has made them who they
are sure they're never going to be like
anyone else in auradon but
that's okay evie's made peace with it
but what exactly happened in evie's
childhood
so so have you not read the rule book
mommy dearest we can't discuss evie's
backstory without looking into her
relationship with her mother the evil
queen is the driving force behind evie's
values at the beginning of the first
descendants movie
although the evil queen seems like the
nicest out of the vk
parents we can't forget that she's a
villain and she can be pretty
intimidating
and scary when she wants to be as evie
says her mother's not a barrel of laughs
when she doesn't get her way and evie
admits to mel that she's sometimes
afraid of her mom
the evil queen tells evie to find
herself a prince who owns a big castle
with a mother-in-law wing
the evil queen is obsessed with looks
and tells evie not to laugh
because it causes wrinkles she also
wants to get rid of evie's unibrow
before she lets her go to auradon
talk about giving the girl a complex
about her looks although she's proud of
evie she's still
all about herself when they ask the
magic mirror who is the fairest of them
all evie quickly changes her answer from
herself
to her mother the evil queen has
equipped evie with the kind of skills
she thinks are most important like
applying cosmetics when evie does mao's
makeup for the date with ben
she reveals that her mom taught her how
to apply blush before she could talk we
also learn about the rest of evie's
education in melissa de la cruz's
prequel novel isle of the lost
let's dive right in evie's childhood we
discover more about evie's upbringing in
the prequel novel
and it's full of so many fascinating
facts about evie's childhood like which
friend she developed a crush on and
which friend she was
actually enemies with throughout her
younger years so hang tight because
we'll be revealing those jaw-dropping
revelations real soon
let's start with what life was like
growing up on the isle in the novel we
learned that the nickname for the isle
of the lost is the isle of the leftovers
that's because it's the dumping ground
for auradon's trash
all of the food makeup and clothing sold
there are leftovers
the book's author says that life there
is dark and dreary and very sad too
because there's no magic the villains
have been reduced to hard scrabble lives
they used to do
everything with magic and now they don't
know how to do anything however that
wasn't the case for evie
if you're wondering what evie was like
as a little kid let us fill you in
in the novel we learned that all the
villains loved her her laugh could make
the tiger from the jungle book sure khan
her contently it could make the wicked
stepmother from cinderella
lady tremaine smile captain hook from
peter pan even braved sticking his head
and tick-tock the crocodile's mouth just
to make evie
laugh but after a run-in with another
villain mom and daughter duo at evie's
sixth birthday party the evil queen and
evie were banished they moved to a
run-down castle far
across the forest where evie is
castle-schooled
we can guess that her mom didn't teach
her academic subjects given what evie
says to chad and the descendants
playing down her brain she insists that
she's not that smart
she says that she is however really good
at cooking and sewing
and cleaning just like chad's mother
cinderella that marks her out from the
other villains we can totally picture
the evil queen teaching evie all of
those skills to make her an appealing
wife to a prince
but 10 years later evie's off to school
and we don't mean auradon prep
what does ice cream taste like homes and
it's sweet and if you eat it too fast it
gives you a headache
school time on the isle the children on
the isle of the lost attend dragon hall
to learn how to be better villains
mother gothel from tangled teaches
selfishness 101
she's one of the villains who's revived
and imprisoned on the isle
unsurprisingly
eevee passes with flying colors other
classes include weird science
unnatural biology wickedness and evil
schemes and nasty plots
evie is enrolled in advanced vanities
class too
no surprise there either the villain
from beauty and the beast gaston's twin
sons are also enrolled in that class
we'll get back to gestan later as he
potentially has an important role to
play in evie's life with all of these
kinds of wicked lessons being taught
it's no wonder evie turned out the way
she did
but what about friends who did evie
first team up with before they became
the core band of four vks
if you think it's mel you're mistaken
evie's surprising crush
we see evie crushing on chad charming at
the beginning of the descendants movie
primarily because of his prince status
and then she finds true love with doug
but she had a different love interest
when she lived on the isle and that was
her first friend at dragon hall
can you guess who it is we'll put you
out of your suspense and announce that
it's
carlos carlos hosts a party at home when
cruella deville is away
and evie ends up trapped in a closet
along with cruella's bear traps
we'll reveal who set up that mean trick
next but carlos saves evie and it brings
them closer together evie discovers that
carlos lives in that closet
and they bond over their shared
experience of isolation their friendship
is solidified when evie shows carlos
kindness
it's thought that these two had a mutual
crush on each other but nothing ever
happened
they stay good friends and evie helps
carlos with his clever inventions
like the device he creates to poke a
hole in the dome over the aisle he hopes
to access
other tv channels and he's successful in
creating a hole for a minute
before it heals right up but not before
it lets enough magic in to revive
maleficent's scepter and her sidekick
diablo
evie and carlos get roped into a quest
to retrieve the scepter
and that leads us onto the topic of
evie's early enemy
who is evie's shocking enemy believe it
or not bffs evie and mao were actually
enemies for
most of their lives on the isle and it
all goes back to evie's lavish 6th
birthday party
evil queen invited everyone except mal
and anyone who's seen sleeping beauty
will know that maleficent does not
respond well to being left off a guest
list
she banishes the evil queen and evie to
a far away castle
and mao holds a grudge against evie that
she's still holding on to when evie
shows up at dragon hall
10 years later in her evil schemes class
mal comes up with her revenge plan
she tricks evie into walking into
corella's closet hoping that she'll be
seriously harmed by the bear traps
cruella uses to protect her fur coats
thank goodness carlos came to the rescue
mal forces evie to accompany her on her
quest
to recover maleficent's scepter mao
plans to make evie grab it as maleficent
has warned her that it will curse
whoever touches it causing them to fall
asleep for a
thousand years with jay and carlos in
tow the gang of four
vks bond on their dangerous mission
through the isle of the doomed and the
forbidden mountain
they have to beat various traps that
relate to their biggest fears
we learned that evie's biggest fear is
to end up not being the fairest in the
land
that says a lot about the impact her mom
had on her evie explains to mel why the
evil queen didn't invite mao to her
sixth birthday party she was bitter that
the villains chose maleficent to lead
them
she thought it should have been her
given that she's royalty
those villain parents cause all the
trouble right fortunately mao shows the
goodness in her heart and sacrifices
herself by grabbing maleficent's scepter
it turns out that mao can't be cursed by
it because of the bloodline
so mal and evie make amends and become
firm friends
dad the daddy question we're finishing
up with a look at who evie's father
could be
we know descendants 3 is going to deal
with the question of mal's dad so
could it also reveal evie's parentage
there are a few
fascinating fan theories about who it
could be the first four candidates all
come from the evil queen's original
movie snow white and the seven dwarfs
given that she was married to snow
white's dad king leopold
could he be evie's father too that would
make evie and snow white have sisters
the evil queen also had a henchman the
huntsman whom she tasked with getting
rid of her stepdaughter
of course he doesn't go through with her
evil plan but could his part in the plot
have gotten him imprisoned on the isle
too
then there's the magic mirror perhaps
that was turned into human form on the
isle
the fourth candidate is grumpy the dwarf
out of all the seven dwarfs he'd be the
one
most likely to end up on the isle
perhaps that connection explains why
evie's attracted to doug
finally and most intriguingly of all
there's gaston from beauty and the beast
he's as obsessed with looks as the evil
queen
so perhaps they bonded over their
fascination with who's the fairest of
them all
gaston's fate after he fell from the
castle was left open
even if he did perish we know from the
prequel book that villains were
resurrected and
imprisoned on the isle and we know that
gaston's three sons live on the isle we
meet gil
in descendants 2 as part of uma's pirate
gang and we meet the twins gaston jr and
gaston iii
in the prequel novel if these two are
evie's half-brothers that would actually
be pretty sweet
because in the book they delight evie by
wrestling and balancing on top of each
other at her birthday party
then they're reunited 10 years later
when evie first arrives at dragon hall
the twins help her find dr fasslier's
office fighting over who gets to open
the door for her
they also offer to share their lunch
with evie and take her on a tour of the
school
could they have had a sixth sense that
they were related who do you think is
evie's father and what do you make of
her secret history with mal and carlos
be sure to let us know in the comment
section below descendants 3 is coming
back this summer and we can't wait to
see mal and the gang again
today we're taking a look at mal's
backstory stay tuned to find out how one
of her enemies became her bff she might
want you to believe she's rotten to the
core
but mal is everyone's favorite vk turned
hero the purple-haired daughter of
maleficent basically ruled the isle of
the lost
she was mean and tough and you can slap
a pirate hat on but you're still shrimpy
and no one dared to cross her she had a
hard time adjusting when she was
selected to move to auradon
she pretended that she was good while
she schemed with her bffs
but mal is anything but evil she's kind
and fights for fairness
she's stylish and cool she's also a
great friend and girlfriend but there's
a lot more to mouth than just what you
see
in the descendants movies thanks to the
novels and other sources of canon we
know a lot about mao's backstory we're
going to take a look at all of these
details so you can know
everything there is to know about mal
we're so excited to learn even more
about her in the third movie
mommy issues we can't talk about mal's
backstory
without talking about her mommy issues
seriously maleficent is basically mommy
dearest
she's just not a good mom it's all about
you and me baby
do you enjoy watching innocent people
suffer here's what we know about
maleficent she had a baby with some
unknown character that she describes as
a weak human
more on that later maleficent is the
worst of the worst villains
she's a powerful magic fairy with the
ability to turn into a dragon
everyone is scared of her even the other
villains maleficent was the most
powerful villain who was banned by king
adam to the isle of the lost
most of her power comes from a magical
scepter she also had a magical spell
book
in the descendant's books maleficent has
a magical bird
maleficent always puts herself above
everyone else including her daughter
she also has her daughter do all her
dirty work in the prequel novel
isle of the lost she makes mal go after
her magical scepter
even though whoever touches it will end
up cursed in the first movie she forces
mao to steal the fairy godmother's wand
which is kept in a museum so that mao
can bring magic back to the island
then she sends a monster after mal and
her friends because she doesn't trust
her
she tries to teach mao to be as evil as
possible
when we first meet mal she wants nothing
more than just to be like her mom
she wants her mom's approval she tries
her best to be as evil as possible
in isle of the lost we learn that mal
was not invited to a birthday party at
age six we'll tell you all about whose
birthday it was in a few minutes
well maleficent was super offended on
behalf of mal
she causes a ton of drama with the other
villain parents
what is it with maleficent getting so
offended by party invitations
seriously it was not getting invited to
princess aurora's christening that led
to all the drama and sleeping beauty
nothing mal ever does is good enough for
maleficent she's not an affectionate
mother and male
isn't quite sure whether her mom even
loves her eventually mal learns that
it's okay to step away from a toxic
parent
even though maleficent is her mother
she's a terrible influence
mal learns about love and acceptance
from her friends and they become her
chosen family
maleficent ends up cursed as a lizard
that mal keeps in her dorm
maybe she'll learn some valuable
parenting lessons while she's trapped as
a reptile
we sure hope so mal's bffs when we first
meet mal and descendants she's the
ringleader of a tough group of bks
her best friends are evie j and carlos
they're the fiercest gang on the isle of
the lost
they're also the first vks chosen to
attend auradon prep you four
have been chosen to go to a different
school in auradon
all of them are excited to get off the
isle but they have a hard time getting
rid of their evil ways
eventually they all find their home and
they find family in each other but have
you ever wondered how they ended up as
friends evie is the brilliant and
stylish daughter of the evil queen from
snow white
everyone thinks she's ditzy because
she's so into fashion but it turns out
that she's
actually really smart we love that eevee
proves you can be both girly and
intelligent according to the books evie
and mal were originally enemies
when evie was six years old she and her
mom did not invite mal to her birthday
party maleficent was cruel and so is mal
who can blame her for not inviting a
party pooper maleficent goes crazy on
the evil queen and mal is super
impressed by how fierce her mom is
mal holds a grudge against evie for
years as teenagers she tries to trap
evie at a party in revenge when
maleficent makes mao go after her
scepter
she recruits evie she was going to make
evie touch the scepter which would make
her fall asleep for a thousand years
while they're on this journey mal
realizes evie is actually an amazing
friend
she doesn't curse her and they become
besties evie always accepts mel without
judgment
by the time they go to auradon prep
they're like sisters
mal's two other best friends are jay and
carlos jay is the son of jafar
he's a thief he was really mao's first
friend on the isle and they make a game
of stealing he has to steal stuff for
his dad to sell at his shop
oh how the mighty have fallen jafar used
to be so
powerful jay ends up becoming a star
athlete at ardan prep
carlos is the son of cruella de vil
gruella forces her son to sleep in her
dressing room because she loves her furs
more than him
she also convinces him that all dogs are
evil mal
originally fakes a friendship with
carlos so that he'll throw a party while
his mother is away
mel wants to trap evie with bear traps
as revenge
but carlos feels bad about it and saves
evie he goes with them to get the
scepter because he's invented a device
that seeks out magic
it was communicating with the scepter at
auradon prep
carlos gets a lot more confident he also
ends up becoming the world's biggest dog
lover
mouse love life if you saw descendants 2
you probably saw some serious chemistry
between mal and harry hook
hi harry just wait it's until
emma gives you back in the first novel
harry is not a character at all
but he's introduced later as the middle
child in the movies there's definitely
some hinting that mal and harry have a
past together
and if you ask the actors they'll tell
you it's true dove cameron and thomas
doherty came up with a backstory for
their characters
they said that they dated which is why
they have such chemistry but according
to the novels this
never actually happened and it's never
directly mentioned in the movies so
it is not canon but dove and thomas
probably came up with this because they
were crushing on each other they're
dating in real life you know
but according to the junior novelization
of the second movie harry is another
love interest
he kisses gill in the books mal says she
doesn't know what love feels like and
she says that no one really dates on the
island but when she comes to auradon she
catches the eye of one handsome prince
ben who later becomes king is totally
enamored by the rebel
he sees good in her from the beginning
it's because of ben that the vks get a
chance to come to auradon in the first
place
mal tries to trick him with a love
potion as part of her scheme
but on their first date he falls into
the lake mal thinks he's drowning and
tries to save him
even though she cannot swim he realizes
that she's a really good person and he
falls for her
even though the love potion is worn off
he lets her think that he's still under
the spell
in the second movie he finds out that
she's been using magic
she runs back to the isle of the lost
but he goes after her
with the help of evj and carlos mal has
to save him from uma
later uma shows up at the cotillion she
has been under a love spell mao kisses
ben using true love's kiss
to break the spell she reveals that she
has been in love with him for a long
time
these two are seriously couple goals
they always see the best in each other
and they encourage each other to be
better
plus they have overcome a lot we can't
wait to see more of their relationship
in the next movie mal's enemies as a vk
now has several enemies
of course mao's biggest enemy is
actually herself she's constantly
fighting against her upbringing
as a villain because deep down she's
actually a good person
wow you almost don't notice your
other features anymore then mal has to
deal with her mom
in the first movie one of mao's main
enemies is audrey when mal
and the other vks first arrive at
auradon prep audrey is dating ben
audrey is a classic mean girl she tries
really hard to sabotage mao's life in
auradon
audrey is not in the second movie but we
know she'll be back in the third movie
and she looks
like a villain in the second movie mal
faces an old enemy
uma is the daughter of ursula she's a
pirate now that mal has left the
island uma is basically the vk in charge
everyone is scared of her she has hairy
hook and gill to do her bidding
but uma and mal weren't always enemies
they used to be friends
they used to team up to play pranks on
people when they were kids
according to isle of the lost they tried
to prank cruella deville but mal falls
off the docks
uma tries to save her but it was a joke
all along
mal dumps a bucket of shrimp on uma's
head she meant it to be funny but uma
didn't think so
no matter how much uma washed her hair
she could never get the fishy smell out
then mal got everyone to call uma
shrimpy
they became sworn enemies after that in
the second movie uma feels left behind
by mal and the other vks
she's super jealous she kidnaps ben so
that mal will give her fairy godmother's
wand but mal gives her a fake
then uma shows up at cotillion she puts
ben under the love spell and
once the spell breaks malinuma have an
epic showdown
uma turns into an octopus-like sea witch
just like her mom
mal also transforms into a creature uma
swims away but we know we haven't heard
the last of her
mouse powers that leads us to one of the
most important things about mal
her powers when she has her fight with
uma mao gets so angry that she turns
into a dragon
she gets this power from her mom but
instead of using it for evil she uses it
to protect her loved ones
also like her mom mao's eyes glow green
when she gets angry
it's a good reminder that mal isn't
fully human she might not be human at
all
actually dove cameron has described her
as a pixie
technically maleficent is an evil fairy
mal
inherits her mom's magical abilities she
is able to cast spells with the help of
the spell book
beware for swear undo jane's hair
she's also very successful at making
potions mel
also has some powers that aren't magical
for one she's
really talented artist in the first
movie we see her spray painting graffiti
she draws a lot throughout the film
mal is also really good with a sword she
had to learn that growing up on the isle
of the lost
now has some pretty cool abilities but
it's definitely her awesome heart that
makes her such a great character
who is mal's dad there's been a lot of
speculation about mal's dad
who is he we know that we're going to
see him in descendants 3.
he was originally described as a weak
human by maleficent but it turns out
that mal's dad
is most likely hades the god of the
underworld from hercules but hades is
not human
you know i know i got it i got the
concept we have so many questions
did maleficent lie about who mal's
father is
so she wouldn't ask too many questions
that seems like something maleficent
would do or
did hades trick maleficent into
believing he was human
villains are pretty sneaky you know we
cannot wait to find out more about mao's
father
what's your favorite thing about mal let
us know in the comments below
and that's it for mal's backstory be
sure to subscribe to the things to keep
up with descendants 3 news
see you next time